this is another question that falls
under radian
measure let's have a look at it together
a wedge is cut so that its
cross-sectional area is a sector
of a circle so that sector that they're
talking about that cross-sectional area
is this guy in here that's the sector
that they're referring to
let's keep going uh a radius 15
centimeters so you can see that that has
been drawn in
on the diagram for us and it's
subtending an angle of pi
on 6. let's just draw that in pi on 6
there at the center
find part a the volume part b the
surface all right so how do we
think about this well to start with when
we think about this wedge it's a weird
kind of shape we don't
deal with wedges very frequently this
wedge
is part of a bigger shape what is
that bigger shape that this wedge was
cut out of well if you want to think
about it this way
i think about pizzas and i also think
about cakes can you tell i'm hungry
this shape here kind of looks like a
slice of cake right and a cake of course
to begin with traditionally is going to
be cylindrical
so this shape has been cut out of a
cylinder if you want to think about this
way
let's try and do a that's going to be my
ellipse there and if you want to think
about
a cake like so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take out of
you know this chunk in here
when i take this guy out that's going to
remove it and then put it on its side
that gives us
the wedge that we're interested in so
when i wanna work out
the volume on this wedge i'm gonna start
with the volume of the shape that it
comes from
the cylinder and then i'm going to work
out what proportion of that cylinder
is relevant so let's have a think about
that i might as well use this diagram of
a cake to help me because i can take the
information that's been provided and
sort of put it onto this cylinder so
what i'll do is
make it a little bit bigger now when you
have a think for starters uh
this radius 15 centimeters that comes
off of this wedge right that radius of
15 centimeters is really referring to
the radius
of the cylinder that the wedge came from
so in fact i can write that as 15
centimeters
right there terribly not to scale but
that's okay because i then need to work
out you know the volume of a cylinder if
you can't recall
is pi r squared h very much like the
uh well identical to the volume formula
for any other
um shape that has this consistent cross
section we would normally call them
prisms but of course prisms
have to all have straight edges i
digress i've got my radius
r i need my height so that's that's this
thing in here right now when you have a
look at my diagram
the original one i should say which of
these numbers is going to be the height
you could get pretty lucky and notice
that there is only one other number that
is relevant to a length
and that is of course this 6 over here
and you can kind of see
right when you have taken this slice out
where this is now lying on its edge but
where did this come from and that is the
height
of the cake so this is going to be six
centimeters
over here now the volume of the cylinder
um doesn't use
this angle in here because um the whole
cylinder is just
um you know a complete revolution but i
can quickly work out what it is using
these two numbers right
pi times that radius of 15
squared multiplied by the height so
that's
225 times 6. i do not know
what my 225 times tables are and i
certainly don't know my six times tables
that far so what i do is i'll just leave
that for a moment and then see if
me and the other part of the question
can help me out here now you can see
the other part of the question is this
angle that the wedge
forms as part of the entire cylinder
now because the angle here is pi on 6
i can work out you know the total
cylinder is 2 pi
so therefore the proportion of the cake
sorry cylinder the proportion of the
cylinder that this wedge
comes from is going to be pi on 6
divided by 2 pi that's the you know the
little section
divided by the whole section so if you
have a think about this
our pies sadly are going to cancel
and that leaves me with 1 over 6 divided
by 2 which is 1 over
12. so therefore i can go over and say
if this is i should have labeled this
actually as the volume of my
cylinder because that's what it is
volume of
cylinder is this therefore the volume of
the wedge
is going to be 1 12 of the volume
of that cylinder so it's going to be
i'll write down a 12th
one over 12 times and then we'll borrow
this right
so you can see here this actually is a
little bit helpful
to me because um some stuff is going to
cancel right i'm going to have what was
what color was i doing before
that 12 i can take out a factor of 6
which cancels over here leaves me with
two
so now i just have 225
pi on two it doesn't cancel any further
that in what units centimeters cubed
that is the volume of my wedge so i'm
done
let's have a look that was part a right
i'll write that part a up there
let's have a go at part b what is the
surface area
of this wedge well surface area
is tricky because you just got to make
sure you don't miss any of the different
parts that make up the surface of it so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take this i don't think i need this
working anymore so i'm going to clear
this guy
out briefly and then think about all of
the different surfaces because i can
only see two
at the moment uh if you want to label
them i can see that the front one
here this is the front
um i also have what i'm going to call
the top but there are other
surfaces that are hidden so how do we
see them well what i'm going to do is
i'm going to draw in these
extra surfaces so we can make sure we
identify them so
if you take this curve over here
and move it over into the back there and
if you also take
this edge here
and move that guy into the back i've got
one
last one which is this one over here
now we have a complete picture through
the diagram i might actually put in a
slightly lighter color because it's
distracting me i think you can still see
that now we can see we don't just have
the front and the top we also have what
i'm going to call
oops i'm still stuck in this mode let's
fix that
um you've also got the bottom
and the back from this angle
and then lastly uh i guess because i'm
starting around names i'm going to call
this part the
curved surface area right every other
surface area is made up of well it looks
to me like
sectors and rectangles so all of those
are
our plane surfaces so what i want to do
is go through each one one at a time and
see if i can work out what they're equal
to
now the first thing i notice is that
you've got some duplication right so the
front and the back
are the same so if i can work out the
area of the front
and the back sorry if i can just work
out the area of the front that will tell
me to
at the back that's not the only
duplication i have even though they're
off at different angles if you think
about cutting that cake
again right like so each of the cross
sections
that you have you know from that
vertical angle they're all the same
as well so therefore the top and the
bottom are also
the same the only area that is unique
that doesn't have another copy of it is
this
curved area over here so let's just
start going through
i'll do them in order of ease so the top
and the bottom are both
rectangles so i'm going to go area of
top is going to be the same as the area
of the bottom which as you can see here
is 15
that's the width and multiplied by 6
that's the the
depth or the length or whatever you call
them right so 6 times 15
that's going to give me 90 so or i
should say 90
square centimeters so i will file that
away for later
um once i've got the top i've got the
bottom let's do the front so the area of
the front is going to be now like we
said this is a sector so i'm going to
need my sector area
formula which is half r squared
theta thankfully i have my r squared my
r
and my theta already given to me in the
question so this is going to be a half
multiplied by let's see here so my r
squared that's
15 squared this seems familiar doesn't
it and then my theta is going to be that
pi
on 6. so what am i getting here
um i'm going to say that's well i'm just
going to evaluate it like so 225 pi
on 12. and because i'm being
exceptionally lazy and using my
calculator a whole lot
let's go ahead and work out what 225
on 12 will be 75 over 4 because of
course there's only a factor of 3.
excuse me that can cancel so 75 pi
on 4 square centimeters all right
so i have my top area which is the same
as the
bottom i've got my front area which is
the same as the back the last one i need
is that curved area
now this one's a bit sneaky because you
might think i don't even know how to
work out
a curved area right well i want you to
come back to this idea of the cylinder
the cylinder if you have a think about
this working out its area its surface
area i should say
is something we've been doing for a
while right so you would say okay i will
do
the top and the bottom in a similar
thought process to how we've been doing
it today and then we do the curved
surface area
but the easiest way to think about the
curved surface area is that if you take
that round part
and then just cut it and unwrap it or if
you want to think about it
imagine if you were trying to wrap a
cake you would just take a
long cylinder and then just wrap it
around into a circular
shape all you need to know is the
length all the way around the cylinder
in other words
its circumference and then that would be
the width the very long width
of your rectangle which would wrap
sufficiently around
so therefore when i think about this
section
the curved section in here what i need
to know
is number one uh what is what is this
length over here
the height of it if as it were because
i'm thinking about it sideways which is
already given to me it's six
and then i need to work out what this
curved arc
is so that's going to be the length of
an arc formula
right once i take those two bits even
though one is curved you can imagine
unwrapping it and you actually just get
a rectangle like before
so therefore let's have a think about
this the area of that
curved section in there we said it's
going to be a rectangle which already
has that height
of 6 and then i'm going to multiply by
well what's going to be our r and our
theta which is our
length of an arc formula right well r is
going to be the 15
and then i'm going to have my theta
which is pi on 6.
so this here is my r theta and if you
want to think about it in
sort of you know a way that's less
confusing because you can see there's a
lot of diagrams
sort of overlapping each other if i just
have a look at
the cross section you can see the cross
sectional area is a sector of a circle
let's just draw that sector
and that'll help convince you here's the
cross
section in here you've got that 15 which
is that long radius
you've got the pion 6 in here and
that's very messy and then what we
worked out was this r theta which is the
15 pi on 6 that we're seeing here now
conveniently for us it's almost like
they designed the question to do this
you're going to have some cancelling
again this 6 and this 6
cancel so that leaves you with 15 pi and
this is an area after all
so i'm getting square centimeters we're
ready to conclude so i can say
total surface area total
surface area equals remember there's two
lots at the top
top and bottom two lots of the front
front back and then there's just one of
the curves so
i'm going to get double of the 90
double of the 75 pi
on 4 and then i'm just going to have a
single lot of the
15 pi so let's just tidy that up a
little bit
that's going to be 180 the 2 and the 4
are going to cancel a little bit giving
me 75 pi
on 2 plus 15 pi
that 15 pi is the same as 30 pi on 2
so that gives me leaving the uh 180
separate from the other guy
a hundred and five pi on two if i'm
crunching my numbers right
on the fly square centimeters and let's
just have a see did they want us to
um approximate they did not so i'm done
that's the surface area so there was a
lot to that question
mainly because number one surface area
questions in general you've got to like
make sure you get every different angle
quite literally and then number two to
work out that surface area
you have to do a lot of work to infer
the different parts and different
dimensions
that are relevant to those especially
you work out that curved surface area
yeah you've got to know where you're
coming from you've got to understand the
shapes
really well so hopefully that's helpful
to you